واشارت حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس بما
اسمته الاداه البطولي لغرفه العمليات
المشتركه ردا على العدوان الاسرائيلي
واكدت حماس على الوحده
والتلاحم الميداني بين المقاومه والشعب في
معركه اثار الاحرار واضافت الحركه في بيان
لها ان جرائم الاحتلال لن توقف مقاومه
الشعب الفلسطيني ووحدته في ملحمه اثار
الاحرار
قال اسماعيل هنيه رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحركه حماس من وصفه بالعدو يتحمل
المسؤوليه عما يجري بسبب جريمه الاغتيال
للقاده واستهداف المدنيين في بيوتهم
واضافانيه في اتصال مع وزير الخارجيه
الايراني ان المقاومه موحده في الميدان
وفي المواكبه السياسيه من جهه اكد الامين
العام لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي في فلسطين
زياد النخاله ان المقاومه في الميدان
بحاله ممتازه واضاف في اتصال مع وزير
الخارجيه الايراني ان للتصدي للعدوان
متواصل الى ان تتوقف الاعتداءات ويقبل
العدو بالشروط الفلسطينيه كما قال